hello everyone welcome back to the
channel today we are here with Vanessa
and Joseph winter they are a couple and
they write produce direct and basically
do everything they can in their movies
uh this year they have released their
first feature movie together that string
that's on shutter and they also made a
segment for vhs99 that's also come to
each other this week so we are here to
discuss a little bit the work production
and talk a little bit about that stream
and vhs99 and there are segments to
Helen back so thank you both for coming
today thanks for having us Martha thank
you so I would like to start by pointing
out some similarities in to Helen Back
Your segment at vhs99 in that stream
they are both over they are both have a
lot of comedy on them and Joseph plays
the main character in both films and
they are both found footage I would and
they are both releasing to one and a
half months apart for for each other did
you work on them together how how did
you manage producing both the segment
for vhs99 in that stream
um VHS 99 came after so deadstream was
completed and premiered at South by
Southwest and afterward we were extended
the invitation to work on VHS 99 so it
they weren't happening at the same time
yeah that stream was actually filmed two
and a half years ago no right
um
it was a long time ago and it's the
post-production took a while and then
the the festival circuit it's been on a
really long tour so
um even though it just came out it
actually feels like we made it a long
time ago but the cool thing about going
from deadstream right to VHS 99 is we
were able to take the same core team
over to it and that gave us some
continuity with um knowing how to pull
off this kind of production and we were
able to use the same kind of camera rig
that we had in deadstream so it was
actually really nice to shoot those
almost back to back yeah uh what's
really really cool About That Swing is
that it uh mimics a live stream so there
are no cuts no visible cuts it happens
as if it was happening in real time and
you took the same approach into Helen
Back uh how did you decide to use the
same approach why what attracts you in
phone footage in both cases the the
non-editing live uh real-time aspect was
Vanessa's idea
um in both cases I had a vision that was
more of an edited presentation where in
deadstream it was supposed to be over
the course of a whole night and it was
kind of edited to just the parts we
needed it to be but she thought it would
be a lot more engaging if the audience
was experiencing it in real time and she
turned out to be right and once I
figured that out then um I was all in
with that same thing with this VHS
segment is I was thinking like okay it
can only be a few minutes and if these
dudes have to figure out how to to get
from Hell back to Earth in just a few
minutes without cutting that's going to
be really difficult to do and it was
difficult however it made it really
thrilling in the story as we started to
construct like they only have eight
minutes how do you actually like it just
kind of increased the stakes and
um had that ticking time component to it
which I think really helped the piece
yeah I like uh I mean I think found
footage is fun because of all the
different possibilities
um it gives you a chance to kind of play
with people's expectations or maybe give
them that feeling that they're more
immersed than other film uh other film
formats because you may feel like you're
the person holding the camera or
something like that and so I um
I liked the forward propulsion of real
time
um for VHS 99 because I think there's
something about it that works well with
our style of Comedy that maybe kind of
just throws you into it or helps you
suspend your disbelief a little bit for
all the silliness and craziness that are
going to happen
um so I I just particularly like the
energy of it but I do think it could be
done other ways and found footage done
other ways is really fun too Funk
footage is really fun but I was really
impressed by both your movies because uh
putting it together like it was in real
time must have been a huge challenge
because found footage is usually cheaper
and easier to make and and hover doesn't
have huge budgets to spend so so it's a
perfect two for horror movies but you've
decided to
put in some extra effort to
glue all together as if it was real time
and that the result is very very
impressive thank you thanks I've also
seen that you work a lot in the art
Department Joseph as a composer to
decide to write in and directing your
movies and I would like to ask how this
previous experiences work in every area
of a movie production reflected on the
work on both that stream and vhs99 and
for me it's um up to this point and
including on both of those Productions
that you mentioned
um they're very small Crews and there's
not really any money with with
deadstream there was a little bit of
money and then with VHS 99 same kind of
thing but before that the short films
that we would make was usually no money
or just I mean like we're talking like a
couple of hundred dollars that kind of
thing and inherent to that our small
Crews and everybody involved wearing
multiple hats particularly us as
directors having also be producers and
edit it ourselves but that actually was
such a valuable skill in all of those
ways having an understanding of how
doing the art Works having hung our own
wallpaper and things like that in shorts
in the past coming into and almost
do-it-yourself project where people are
working for very little or free
sometimes and having an understanding of
what it takes to do it and an
appreciation of what the crew members
are having to do to pull off a feature
film
um with very little resources and I kind
of felt like there was a mutual respect
because of that I think people that we
worked with got the sense and could tell
that we had done this kind of thing
before and we were very appreciative of
the scrappiness that looked like the
scrappy situation that they were in and
putting stuff together I feel like that
just helped the the camaraderie of the
situation feeling like we were all on
the same team yeah that being said our
creature designer and makeup effects
team our department and costume
Department are very very professional
and they brought to both of these
projects it was basically the same crew
and same team and they brought so much
to it with their passion and their ideas
and I definitely don't want it to seem
like we were doing it all even though we
were wearing multiple hats we had crew
members that are I mean we're just so
lucky to work with them they're so
talented yeah very Stellar I mean every
crew member that we had was by far
better at the jobs we have done before
on previous films and we're very
fortunate in that way so I was intending
to talk about a creature design because
the creature designing both that stream
and the on especially onto Helen back
where you you got a little bit more
creative
representing demos was spectacular do
you come with the a part of the creature
design yourselves or do you delegate
completely to another crew member how
how do you work with your creature
design uh we usually have some ideas
but then Troy Larson is our creature
designer he usually takes it to the next
level so an example would be in vhs99 we
were looking at some old medieval
paintings by Bosch that kind of have
these like half animal half people
designs and so we were bringing those to
Troy and I I've been given permission to
give this spoiler about VHS 99 which
there is a creature in there that's half
woman half maggot and he came up with
the name for her of were made and it's
one of my favorite creatures so that's
an example of us kind of bringing a
concept to him but him like taking it
and then realizing it as an actual
monster and bringing his own personality
and next levelness to it yeah the kind
of talks that we would have are like um
this is the gag that's in the story We
reference movies like in deadstream we'd
say movies like house or Creep Show and
that kind of personality coming through
with the character but this is the
function and then he would come back to
us and say anatomically what if it could
do this or what if the creature had this
with the there is a
I'll say it there is a winged demon you
can't have a Hell movie I mean people
are gonna assume there's a winged demon
in the movie but he was thinking what if
it was like not what you've
traditionally seen but it was part of
hell where maybe this person's hell is
that their wings are growing out of
their tissue like their spine their
skeletal structure and every time the
wings expanded it would hurt them and
it's awesome it's so much better that
way because he came up with that and
then with Michaela's the same kind of
thing
um with Michaela Kester is the makeup
effects artist who also designed some of
the creatures in hell yeah and and with
the makeup is that same thing we come to
her with what we think it should be and
then she just starts going and
presenting us with stuff her own ideas
which make it so much better another
thing that I noticed in both that screen
and to hell and back is that you
you like to use practical practical
effects so there are a lot of
Prosthetics there are a lot of makeup
work and this gives a unique look to
your movies that is great it's amazing
and uh why did you choose to use so much
a practical practical effects it was
budget related or it was some sort of
preference uh it just comes from Passion
uh we both love the art of practical
effects and we really admire it and love
being a part of it we're watching it
happen on set
um well that's my personal answer anyway
it's just passion I also like the
texture that it brings to film and
horror specifically
um well for me the first thing when I
was I had it before or five
um the first aspect of horror that made
me want to be a filmmaker or be involved
on that side of the camera was watching
the making of Thriller where um there's
a part you can see the zombies after a
shoot peeling latex off of their face
and when I was a kid I mean that was
amazing and and then seeing movies
evolved to where they started being CG
and it wasn't very good and it still
isn't often times when they're thrown in
horror movies it just made me feel like
well that's not what I signed up for
these aren't the movies I was consuming
it looks way different it's not scary
and so we've we've tried to make it a
point to bring back fun practical event
of effects and it also feels like it's
kind of a Dying art seems to be having a
comeback right now which is great but um
we will do VFX when needed to tell the
story and VHS 99 there were certain
blood gags that didn't work most of the
blood stuff did work and looks awesome
but there were parts that didn't and we
had Justin Martinez an amazing bfx
artist help us out with some augmented
blood stuff and I mean we love that kind
of thing too and we'll probably continue
to use that when it's not practical to
go practical you are absolutely right
practical effects look a lot better in
general I feel like VHS takes a lot of
effort to
look real and yeah it's a great choice
that you use a lot of practical effects
oh there's some great ones there's some
great ones in the other segments
yeah yeah it was some other segments all
the segments of vhs99 have amazing
creatures that is something that they
really step up their game last year with
uh 94 and this year with 99 is amazing
it's brilliant
and about the vhs99 at how is the work
process of making a segment for vgs for
the franchise do you get free reign uh
do you have a runtime that you must
respect do you have a a theme that you
must discuss with someone or are you
free to do whatever you want
um it's pretty at least in our
experience it's very um
it's very friendly to taking risks and
kind of doing your own thing I think
that that's kind of the premise of BHS
is to let the individual voices happen
even though it's an anthology when
people sign up for a VHS movie they
expect each segment to be very different
um so there was there was definitely
some collaboration and talking through
ideas with the producers
um but we were pretty much left up to do
what we wanted to do
it was actually pretty incredible and
shocking at every step of the way where
we would say this is what we're gonna do
and then we'd be like they're gonna say
no that's too silly but instead it'd be
like we love it no go do it and um I
mean there were a couple of Parts where
we were uh needed some additional
support and I would call Josh Goldblum
the producer and he was really
supportive about trying to get us what
we needed to realize our true vision of
what this health segment should be and
the the note that we had going in was
come up with a concept that's between 15
and 20 minutes but then I was having a
conversation with Josh later about the
edit and what if it's longer than 20
minutes and he said but if it's the best
25 minutes that we've ever seen then
that's fine like they just wanted it to
be the best version of what it needed to
be there weren't a lot of um rules going
in and that was yeah it was great yeah
all the producers on VHS are true horror
lovers and they I mean I can't imagine a
more stellar dollar producer lineup yeah
it was so great I'm already excited to
see whatever you come up with next so I
have to ask are you working already on a
new short movie or maybe a feature
nothing that's been greenlit uh but we
do have multiple projects that were
actively working on hoping to have some
news very soon well I do have you hope
you have news very very soon because uh
both that stream and your segment of
vhs99 are amazing and I hope to see more
of your work soon enough thanks so much
Marco yeah thank you before letting you
go uh we are still in Halloween month
this is still October so I would like to
ask you
what are your three favorite horror
movies
I'll go first I have mine okay so
um Creep Show
the gate
and here's my three and Monster Squad
Silver Bullet and The Shining
that's okay
um it's reasonable
I won't I won't say my favorite but I'll
say some recommendations for Halloween
month there's
um a 70s movie called let's scare
Jessica to death
which I think everybody should watch
um dude I'm gonna do all 70s movies uh
don't look now is another favorite of
mine and there's also one that I don't
hear talked about as much called burnt
offerings
um that I've been thinking a lot about
so
those are my threes yeah all three of
those have great
um textures and Aesthetics that are like
totally appropriate for Halloween month
perfect thank you so much for joining us
and if you are watching this interview
at home both that string and vhs99 are
available right now at shutter and you
should definitely check that out thank
you Vanessa thank you Joseph and see you
later
thanks Marco talk to you soon so nice to
meet you